okay so he goes e4 and
we have been playing those of you who
were here for uh the speedrun two days
ago i played the night or
for the first time i think he's in balls
deep so f4
we have faced this move once during the
speed run and as you guys will remember
the main drawback of this move is that
it um is that it well it's a move on the
flank and you're not developing
so the general way to respond to such
moves is to strike in the center so
the move is d5 that is the theoretical
move that's often why the grand prix
attack starts with knight c3
because you prevent the move d5 so d5
and as you guys might remember thank you
rasana 29
as you guys might remember if white
takes that pawn then actually taking
back with the queen is considered to be
inaccurate because of knight c3
chasing the queen away uh does anybody
remember
what the move is after e takes d5
[Music]
what is the move after he takes d5 how
do we take that pawn on our own terms
what do we need to do first
gerald b thank you knight f6 is the move
good job
um knight f6 is the move and if white
tries to defend the pawn with c4 i'll
talk about that after the game
i've explained that before okay knight
f6 maybe he'll play c4 now that'll allow
us to demonstrate
why black gets good compensation for the
pawn otherwise
then we take the pawn with a knight and
that way our queen is not going to get
pushed around
so knight f6 is sort of a typical little
idea still theory
and brad thinking here yeah so why does
a couple of moves here white white can
go knight c3 but
already white is slightly worse there
that pawn on f4 is sticking out like a
sore thumb
well bishop e6 would blunder the bishop
right and bishop e6 that pawn can take
the bishop so c4 he goes now
the reason that c4 is a very weakening
move is because it
weakens the d4 square and it also makes
it hard to develop the bishop actively
also white is just moving his pawns so
but in order to exploit
all of that we need to get rid of the
spawn this pawn on d5 right
is stopping my knight from coming out to
c6
one move that occurs to a lot of people
is b5 but
b5 is met with b3 and white preserves
the pawn chain
okay so this is one of the examples
where we violate the role attack the
base of the pawn
here we attack the tip of the poncho
because we're trying to get rid of it
we're trying to get rid of the tip of
the punching and while we are at it
we're going to take on e6 with a bishop
simultaneously developing our bishop
after we play bishop take c6 our
advantage is going to be composed
of three separate things number one is
of course the lead in development right
we're gonna have two pieces developed
and we're gonna have them developed well
black white as zero
number two is the long-term weakness of
white's king even if white castle's
short
the fact that white has played f4 means
that the king will never be quite
perfect
and number three what have i not
mentioned yet what other property of the
position i mentioned this
earlier uh gives black very nice
compensation for the pawn
other than lead in development well it's
not
it's not necessarily weak pawns the
pawns themselves are not that weak
because this pawn can be defended with
d3 it's the d4 square right
it's it's this square that we can reach
with our knight at our leisure we don't
need to rush to come to d4
we can complete our development first
it's okay but at some point
we can we can execute some sort of a
plan
that uh that allows us to slam a knight
into d4 that's a very nice long-term
outpost 92
okay so this move immediately okay
battery's low
one second my headphone battery's low
again
do i need to charge my other headphones
i'm doing this weird thing
one second guys i think about what we
should do 92 is a pretty passive move
so when i see the move92 the first thing
i notice is that if we put our oh yeah
this just wonders upon actually we don't
need any of that this just takes the pun
so i actually thought of knight before
uh which actually might also be very
interesting trying to checkmate him on
d3
but um he would have moved his knight
away to g3 knight before was also good
but this is very simple we win the pawn
back
and black is much better this is kind of
an opening disaster for brad
and um white f4 is not a mistake but
white needs to know exactly what he's
doing to avoid getting a worse position
so here
the best move is either knight f3 or d3
to defend the pawn okay
knight g3 now of course we have a
potential trade which means we need to
evaluate it
uh do you guys think and when i ask this
question
a lot of people misinterpret it and they
assume that the answer is no
do we want to trade on f1 or if somebody
thinks the answer is no then are there
any alternatives yes we do
the reason we want to trade is because
it's going to make it very hard or
outright impossible for white to castle
if white takes with a knight then
castling is not possible because the
knight is in the way
and if he takes with either the rook or
the king then
castling will not be possible for the
rest of the game and why
is that a big deal because the king is
obviously very weak
now just because white can't castle
doesn't mean the black shank
shouldn't castle so let's prepare
castling now we have two squares for the
bishop bishop d6 or bishop e7 tricky
question guys which one do you think i
should play
this is a chance to develop a nuanced
understanding of how to develop pieces
thank you
hepburn curious is absolutely right
bishop e7 bishop d6
optically looks more active but bishop
d6 maybe allows a nasty check on e2
and also remember our queen may one day
want to access the d3 square
this square or maybe our knight wants to
access it and it's a good idea
for the queen to maintain contact with
that square your pieces should not be in
each other's way
and the point of bishop b7 this bishop
is not going to be directly involved in
the
attack we want to talk our king away
first so we don't have to constantly
worry about it when we're attacking
okay and a lot of people i know would
play like knight before
they would go for d3 immediately that's
probably not bad but there is absolutely
no need for us to rush
we can just go here and we can castle
this move doesn't
really accomplish all that much if he
takes then we take with that's another
benefit of putting the bishop on e7
it defends the knight so castles
knight takes f6 okay so d3 so the move
d3 is understandable brad is trying to
get
get his pieces out but but d3 obviously
is also a big weakness
and we already know that there is a
straightforward way to exploit that
weakness that's one candidate move which
is what
knight p4 but there's actually a bit of
an issue with knight before
and the issue with knight b4 is that he
might be able to defend the pawn with
rook f3
okay and then he might chase the knight
away with a3 so i'm actually not as big
of a fan of knight
knight before as i thought initially
what i want to find is a more sustained
way of attacking the d3 pawn i think
knight b4 is a little bit too committal
right
because maybe i'd want to put the knight
on d4 let's not commit
to a placement of the knight just yet um
could anybody propose an alternative
method
of piling up on the d3 pawn
well c4 he just takes guys c4 he takes
on c4 because the knights protect each
other
yes nightmare let's go queen d7 rook d8
this is a standalone good move right
we're just bringing pieces into the game
but even if we don't end up winning d3
then it's still going to be a good move
and also white can still go rook f3 but
then we actually could play knight d4
that that is a good reason why we keep
our knight on c6
because if he does play rook f3 then
knight d4 comes with tempo
the reason we put the a rook and not the
f rook is because if we put the a rook
then the f
could go to e8 which is also a very good
place if we put the f rook on d a the a
rook is not going to have any good spots
okay so he
it's exactly what happens he goes rook
f3 and we can go 94
centralizing our knight with tempo we
didn't even have to go 94 we could have
still gone rook d8
but who can resist such a move okay what
should we do now
let's increase the pressure now just
because we went knight d4 doesn't mean
we shouldn't execute our original idea
uh rook d8 is still a good move now it
is true that we are not actually
attacking d3 but we are putting
preliminary pressure on it
and once we move the knight away from d4
maybe to f5
the d3 pawn is going to get caught in
the crossfire also the oh we had a much
better move though
i actually missed the tactical
opportunity here let's see if we
we have that chance again yeah bishop h4
yeah i missed it um
i did not apply my own advice the rook
got on the same diagonal as the king and
now brad corrects his mistake now the
good news is that we are still winning
because i am just attacking him from all
sides here and
let me try to redeem myself with a cool
move
uh actually let me not so as i mentioned
we now have this big pressure on
on d3 uh it's not that easy to
exploit this pressure but the first step
is we should probably move the knight
out of d4
because this rook is going to get in a
lot of trouble so how how should we do
that what is a good
move that we can make with tempo yeah
knight f5
and then what you guys should see is
that the queen and the rook
are facing off with white's queen which
means that a move that was proposed
earlier in another context
is now actually very good and that is
the move c5 to c4
he cannot take the pawn because we are
going to win a piece
but if he doesn't take the pawn then we
are not only going to win a pawn
but look at that monster that's gonna
appear on d3 it's gonna be a past pawn
and an extra pawn and the knight on e4
is gonna lose its support this is just
going to be nasty now we need to keep an
eye on
our king because we i can see that the
brad
he's got some ideas connected with queen
h5
um but none of that is dangerous because
there's not enough pieces
on the board and this is going to
backfire the reason i know this is going
to backfire is because white king is
simply too weak
to sustain any kind of prolonged attack
and as those of you with a tactical mind
should see the queen is let's let me
apply that advice this time the queen is
making contact
it's an x-raying the g4 pawn which means
the knight could move away
with a discovered check which means that
we can play knight takes g4
and if he takes with the queen then
knight e3 is an elementary discovered
check
tactic we win the queen so knight takes
you for
is devastating for white but i
understand why he played g4 it's a
sensible move but it doesn't work
okay hopefully everything i'm saying is
making
sense so far the game is not over i mean
white can still try to resist but now
the material losses have
begun and then i mean it's virtually
unsalvageable for for white
okay so let's see
how this proceeds okay queen takes g4
the brad settles on it but of course as
you guys can see by the way knight g3
check it's it's important to always
choose the right discovery don't just
throw your knight out with check
i mean if you go knight g3 track that's
bad for many reasons queen takes g3 or
rook takes g3
gets out of the discovered check the
knight e3
and queen takes you for is coming in
regardless of what he does
the game is over we're up a queen for
two pieces and what remains
is relatively simple technique so where
should we move our queen
we have many good choices we can move it
to e6 so that it protects the c4 pawn
um i don't think he missed it i just
think he took out a desperation i think
he
he you know he tries to create him which
is understandable he's trying to mix
things up
the problem is uh not that this is
inherently bad but more like
you know we're going to go queen h5 just
to attack h2
uh we're going to attack h2 notice that
knight f6 check would be something we'd
have to be careful about
but here that bishop on e7 is the unsung
hero because it's guarding that square
yeah queen d7 is possible but then we
give up c4
so i like queen h5 because we're
maintaining contact on the d3 pawn and
we're attacking h2
but this is just horrible for white yeah
no i'm sure brad didn't miss this i i
just think he's
he's desperate to create counter play
but okay now we can take this pawn if we
take that pawn then he'll go f6
and he will attack the g7 pawn so let's
instead take
this pun and now let's take
this pun and now his entire position
collapses
we could have taken it with a pawn but
we're gonna take it with a rook because
we're trying to trade pieces
and the good thing about this move is if
the bishop moves then we can take
white's rook
and simplify the position a little bit
f5 is also a big threat
this is all very very simple and there's
many ways to win this position so that's
a pretty instructive game um
and the opening really made it tough for
brad too to maintain any kind of
serious defensive chances good game good
game brad and let's let's go over it
so the move f4 right the move four would
have been
good were it not for g5 like d5 is the
reason why a lot of people
start with the move knight c3 and only
after black plays d6 or e6
does or knight c6 does white go f4 this
is called a grand prix attack i highly
recommend that by the way
so f4 d5 um in the first game where we
faced this
i think our opponent played e5 which
gives the bishop a very nice
square on f5 oh
my lands and the brad coming through
with
4 000 bits my man
thank you the bread holy smokes that's
huge
4 000 bits ladies and gentlemen by the
brad 77
777 thank you man really appreciate it
um yeah so e5 bishop f5 is kind of like
a good french
for black so he takes d5
i appreciate it man good game knight f6
so the rationale behind this move should
now make sense
c4 is fine e6 and again black gets full
compensation for the pawn
if anything i think probably black is
slightly better here and knight g2 is
the mistake like i get that
you know you were probably trying to get
the knight to g3 brad to go out five
but white's position is just a little
bit too flimsy to allow that so d3 i
think
would have been the more sensible move
followed by knight f3 and bishop b2 and
castle and you get a position kind of
like
okay black will probably go bishop e7 or
bishop d6
and um you get a position like this
which is
i wouldn't say you know anything
disastrous for white white is actually
quite solid here it's it's hard for
black to
break through directly but black play is
very easy i mean you can just position
your pieces on good squares
and eventually you can go after that
pawn um
so so this is just not quite that good
okay frank run thanks for the 20 months
appreciate it frank
uh you're the man so knight g2 bishop c4
already the position is almost lost
because without this pun uh the roof
just basically comes off so knight g3
takes takes i'm gonna replace my
headphones one second
thank you apollo and diana for the prime
and bishop e7 now by the way just wanted
to point out knight before
had a nice detail oh my god
these dragon thing for the tier one now
if white goes d4
if white goes d4 then after
c takes d4 knight takes d4 it is black
to play and win
this is a very typical tactical idea
that occurs
when the knight is on b4 or d4 you guys
should be aware of this from
a different line that i showed i if you
guys have a good memory
i'm just kidding i mean this is not easy
to remember but i showed hafu
a a system for black that involves a
trap
much like this if you it's called the
baltic the baltic defense d4 d5 c4
bishop f5 i've played this before so you
guys should
should be somewhat familiar with this
knight c3 e6 and then the baltic has
this trap
where if white just nonchalantly plays
e3
then black has this move knight b4 and
it's actually very hard to stop knight
c2 and if white tries to cut the losses
by intercepting the bishop and then
going 95
black to play
like to play
obviously it's the same idea you take a
pawn here not the knight
but it's the same exact idea in the
jebaba there's the same idea
so you should just file this away in
your kind of mental rolodex
of tactical ideas so that's part of what
appealed to me about knight before but
then i saw that or you guys pointed out
that i could take on c4 and that's just
simpler
so it takes things bishop b7 everything
very simple we castle
queen d7 okay um
yeah for some reason why am i on wi-fi
and not ethernet i don't know whatever
should be still good so queen d7 right
now night before rook f3
uh somebody made a point about the rook
being awkward on f3
um i don't think so actually because
also you're paving the way for the king
to walk over to g1 and complete the
manual castle thank you
just mean for five gifted subs to the
community
bellstone shrimp titties blind orc
rip chads and ginger ale three all
getting
subs thank you for the five gifted chess
man appreciate it
um loving the support today as as per
usual guys
um seven holding strong at 7 500 subs
plus that's awesome okay
so knight before was possible but
probably not not the best we go queen d7
knight d4 um and rook d8 just bringing
the pieces in and now knight f5
um knight f5 um
and we open up the pressure on on the d3
pawn here right
we open up the pressure on the d3 pawn
in order to be able to go c4 there was a
kind of cool move
where we could go c4 first we could go
c4 first
and then go knight f5 and this is also
good
because if queen takes d7 you have to
look for intermediate moves in this kind
of situation and an
intermediate move exists you take the
rope with check very important that it's
check
and then you are up in exchange so that
would have been a possibility but there
was a reason i didn't play c4 and i
don't remember why
but it would have also been interesting
i just decided to keep it simple knight
f5
rook h3 and now c4 is absolutely
crushing i mean
i think white can defend a little bit
more resiliently but g4 is
understandable now knight takes g4
and the situation just gets even worse
and now black white is just lost
maybe i don't know maybe knight takes f6
and then replace the knight with the
other knight maybe
that way but now just bishop b7 and
again like look at white's position the
king everything is weak
and ct oh yeah bishop h4 was missed of
course i missed
i missed knight takes e4 and and then
bishop h4
and that uh wins the exchange that just
wins the exchange because it's a pin
and the move knight f6 check the bishop
multitasks as a defender of the f6
square
remember that this kind of stuff is
often possible even if
a piece is pinned it can still be the
pin
pinner a piece can be pinned and pin
another piece
that's a tongue twister but you guys see
what i'm saying rook is pinned but it
pins the g pawn
however the bishop takes f6 that's kind
of funny so a piece that is being pinned
the rook is currently pinned by the
bishop can also in
itself be a pinner
like a rokon g3 is pinning the pawn on
g7 that's kind of funny the pin pinner
how many pins to the pinpin are pinned
so which could chuck wood
okay enough enough enough enough
conception is right
um
you